حسنًا، يقول رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريتشي سوناك إنه
يريد استعادة الاستقرار في
البحر الأحمر وتهدئة التوترات،
واصفًا ضربات التحالف الأسبوع الماضي على
أهداف في اليمن بأنها الملاذ الأخير، لكن
الهجوم الجديد يزيد من
المخاوف المتزايدة من حرب إقليمية محتملة.
أعلن المتمردون
مسؤوليتهم عن هجوم صاروخي على
سفينة شحن مملوكة للولايات المتحدة اليوم،
ويقول الجيش الأمريكي إن السفينة تعرضت
لأضرار طفيفة ولم تكن هناك إصابات على متنها،
ويجب أن تسمع جيدًا أن الولايات المتحدة والمملكة
المتحدة قصفت العشرات من أهداف باي في اليمن
الماضي  أسبوع ردًا على
الهجمات المتكررة على الشحن الدولي،
فلنتعرف على المزيد حول كل هذا،
ينضم إلي الآن أورين لامان من شبكة CNN، وما الذي
نعرفه أكثر في هذه المرحلة عن هذا
الهجوم الأخير على هذه الشحنة المملوكة لنا،
لذا يبدو أن هذه هي
المرة الأولى  لقد رأينا هوي
يضرب بنجاح سفينة مملوكة لنا وتديرها الولايات المتحدة،
جيال جالتر إيجل وفقًا
للقيادة المركزية الأمريكية، فقد أصيبت السفينة
بصواريخ باليستية مضادة للسفن
بصاروخ وهو أحد الأسلحة التي
رأينا إطلاقها مرارًا وتكرارًا  مرة
أخرى وكانت الضربة نفسها في
خليج عين جنوب اليمن كما
ترون على الخريطة هناك تعرضت السفينة نفسها كما
أشرت لأضرار طفيفة
ولم يصب أي من طاقمها لذلك تمكنت من
مواصلة طريقها الآن  بالطبع
ننتظر لنرى ما سيحدث من هنا،
أوضحت الولايات المتحدة أنه إذا استمر أصحاب القلنسوة في
مهاجمة الشحن الدولي
فسيكون هناك رد فعل أمريكي آخر، وقد
رأينا الموجة الأولى من الضربات الأمريكية والضربات البريطانية
ليلة الخميس هنا بتوقيت العاصمة، وقد رأينا
الولايات المتحدة  نفذت بضع ضربات أخرى حتى
اليوم التالي، والآن أصبح السؤال هو:
هل تشعر الولايات المتحدة أنها بحاجة إلى الرد على
هجوم مباشر على سفينة أمريكية؟
قد يكون الجواب نعم، وفي هذه
الحالة سيكون نوع الهدوء والأمن
الذي توفره الولايات المتحدة.  وكانت الولايات المتحدة تتطلع إلى جلبها إلى
البحر الأحمر، ولم يكن ذلك في الأفق بعد